وثلاث قمم ستضغط على زياره الرئيس الصينيه
للسعوديه قمه سعوديه صينيه
واخرى خليجيه صينيه وثالثه عربيه صينيه ما
يعطي الزخمه لهذه الزياره للعلاقات جيدا
السعوديه الصينيه في جده الموضوع
سنخصصه اذا لوقفا مع الحدث مع زميل خالد
الغربلي اهلا بك خالد هذا سؤال يضل ملحن
ما الذي تريده الرياض من بكيني
نحن قادرون على ان نفتح لكم ابواب
السعوديه اهم اقتصاد في منطقه الخليج
العربي وليس فقط السعوديه الخليج العربي
بل حتى اسواق كثيره في الدول العالم
العربي من خلال هذه القمم الثلاث همم
هناك نقاط مشتركه بيننا وبينكم ان كنتم
لديكم طريق همم مبادره الطريق الطريق
الحرير همم تريدون ان تنقلوا صناعتكم الى
العالم من خلال محطات تتوقفون فيها
السعوديه هي واحده من هذه المحطات ليست اي
محطه بل واحده من ربى من اهم المحطات في
المنطقه لان السعوديه هي اهم اقتصاد في
المنطقه وهي تطمح ان تستغل الموقع
الجغرافي لها بان تقوم صله تكون صله ربط
بين افريقيا واسيا وتكون حتى قوه اقتصاديه
عالميه وليس فقط اقليميه ومن هنا نستطيع
ان نجد مشاريع مشتركه تخدم مشروع طريق
الحرير وتخدم مشروع رؤيه 2000 اا 2030
بالنسبه للسعوديه ونطور علاقاتنا
الاقتصاديه معكم وبالتالي هي تعرض هذه
الشراكه على همم على الصينيين وتريد منهم
ان يقوموا بالمزيد من الاستثمار حجم
التبادل التجاري العام الماضي بين البلدين
وصل الى 80 مليار دولار هو ليس كافي
بالنسبه للطرفين يريدان تطوير هذه
العلاقات هي هو في تزايد
الشهور ال 10 الاولى من هذا العام بلغ
الحجم التجاري نحو 97 مليار دولار لكن
النسبه الاكبر كانت ل- السعوديه تصدر
لاصين لما ما هي ما هو الذي تصدره بشكل
اساسي المنتجاتا النفطيه منتجات الطاقه
بنحو سته 66 مليار دولار مقابل نحو 30
مليار دولار تصدر همم بها الصين منتجاتها
الى السعوديه وهذا ليس بالكثير نظرا
لامكانيات السعوديه وامكانيات الصين ومن
هنا همم السعوديون يقولون للصينيين نحن
نريد المزيد من الاستثمارات
الصينيه داخل السعوديه ويمكن ان يسهل لكم
ذلك في منطقه خليج وحتى في عديد من من
العديد من الدول العربيه وبالتالي يواجهون
رساله
رغبه في تطوير العلاقات مع الصينيين همم
والرساله ايضا حتى الانحلفاء الخليجيين ان
عنوان التعامل مع الصين يتم من الارض
السعوديه لانه هناك منافسه بين رياض ودبي
على من هي ما هو مركز التجاره العالميه في
هذه المنطقه بالاضافه طبعا الرساله الاهم
السياسيه هي للولايات المتحده انكم لستم
وحدكم في هذه المنطقه ان كنتم ترفضون
التعاون معنا في بعض المجالات وان كانت
هناك موضوع حقوق الانسان يعرقل العلاقات
بيننا هناك دوله الصين لا تهتم كثيرا
بالحديث عن موضوع حقوق الانسان وهي مستعده
لتطوير العلاقات ونحن نرغب وقادرون على
تطوير العلاقات معها هذا طبعا نفهم منه ان
الولايات المتحده تراقب بعين من القلق ما
يحدث لكن ليس بالكثير من القلق لماذا لانه
صحيح ان الصين تستطيع ان تطور علاقات
الاقتصاديه همم مع السعوديه لكن الحاجه
الامنيه الورقه الامنيه ليست في يد الصين
لان علاقات الصين مع العالم هي علاقات
اقتصاديه يمكن ان تؤدي الى حقها الى نفوز
سياسي لكن ما تقدمها الولايات المتحده من
حيث انها القوه العسكريه الاولى في العالم
ومن خلال قواعدها العسكريه المنتشره في
منطقه الخليج
وايضا من خلال بيعه ل الصفقات الاسلحه كل
هذا يؤهلها لان تكون هي من قادره على ان
تقول نحن قادرون على ان نكون معكم من
الناحيه الامنيه في الماضي كان حمايه الان
من قدرات العسكريه الامريكيه وانتشار في
المنطقه لا تقوم حرب لا تنده لحرب في هذه
المنطقه بدون نوع من الموافقه الامريكيه
ولا تستمر حرب في هذه المنطقه بدون حر
بدون دعم الامريكي من خلال التسليح
وبالتالي ما تقدمه الولايات المتحده امنيه
السعوديه الاخيره التي تستخدم السعوديه في
حرب اليمن مثلا غالبا هي امريكيه هي تلزم
ابقى علاقات جيده مع الجانب الامريكي
وتطور علاقات كثيره مع الصين ودخول اوروبا
مع في من الناحيه العسكريه هذا قد يزعج
الامريكيين وقد يؤثر على تطوير العلاقات
مع الامريكيين لكن هي ورقه ان اردت
استخدمها السعوديه لدخول الامريكيين هناك
حليف اخر يمكن ان نعتمد عليه لكن طبعا
هناك حدود
طيب خالد همم
تنقلات رئيس الصيدلي كانت همم قليله في
الاونه الاخيره وهنا ربما تكسير اهميه
الكبرى
ناتي الى مصلحه الصين من كل ذلك
الصين قوه الصين هي في اقتصادها الاقتصادي
يحتاج الى محرك والمحرك والطاقه السعوديه
من احد اهم والردي الطاقه لا الصين
وبالتالي العلاقات لابد ان تحافظ الصين
على علاقه جيده مع السعوديه نحو 17% من
النفط الذي تستخدمه الصين ياتي من
السعوديه وهناك المشاريع التي يتم بحثها
حاليا هي في مجال الطاقه وارامكو تستثمر
في مشروع في الصين من نحو عشره مليارات
دولار استثمارات السعوديه
الهدف هو الانتقال بمنتجات الصينيه الى
العالم
وواحده من مناطق العالم هي منطقه الشرق
الاوسط واهم اقتصاد ليس فقط في منطقه
الخليج بل في كل المنطقه العربيه ومنطقه
الشرق الاوسط هو الاقتصاد السعودي
ناتج المحلي وصل الى العام الماضي الى 800
مليار دولار تاليها الامارات بنحو 400
مليار وبالتالي همم
مجال للاستفاده دوله اثريه جدا تريد تحتاج
الى تطوير البنيه التحتيه لديها رؤيه
لتطوير نفسها للوصول الى ان تكون قوه
اقتصاديه عالميه
وفرصه للشركات الصينيه لتدخل
وتاسستمر لتقوم بمشاريع والتجني الارباح
لتكون هناك محطه قويه للصين للوصول
بمنتجاتها الى دول اخرى من خلال موضوع همم
طريق الحرير اذا من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
همم كلها فائده بالنسبه للصنين ومن الواضح
ان يعتمدون من الممكن ان يعتمدوا على
السعوديين ايضا بما للسعوديه نفوز على دول
منطقه الخليج وعلى ايضا من خلال علاقات
السعوديه همم في بعض الدول العربيه الاخرى
لكن هناك ايضا رساله للامريكيين انه في
نهايه الامر ان كنتم انتم تنتشرون في
المنطقه نحن في قلب منطقه نفوذ امريكا
منطقه الخليج هم لهم شراكه استراتيجيه مع
الايرانيين وقوعها حدث عن الصينيين والان
نتحدث عن السعوديه اهم قوه اقليميه واكثر
الدول ثراء في المنطقه واكثر الدول التي
يمكن ان يستفيد منها الاقتصاد الصيني ومن
هنا ليس فقط تحقيق مصالح اقتصاديه قد تؤدي
في وقت لاحق الى نفوذ سياسي ايضا لكن ايضا
توجيه الضرب لان نفوذ الامريكي في المنطقه
يقولون الامريكيين نحن نبني نفوزنا في
منطقه عرفت تاريخيا في السنوات
العقود الماضيه انها منطقه نفوذ امريكيه
وبالتالي هناك مصلحه كبيره لصين لتطوير
هذه العلاقات وان بقيت على المستوى
الاقتصادي ولا تصل الى حد المستوى العسكري
لان الصين ليس في فلسفه الان ان تدخل ان
توفر حمايه عسكريه ان اردتي لدول معينه
لكن يمكن ان تشارك في بعض المساهمات في
الصناعات العسكريه فقط جزيره شكرا
جزيلا لك